my guest tonight won an Emmy Award for
his performance in the British comedy
series State of the Union he also had
hilarious roles and this is 40 in
bridesmaids his latest movie here we are
notes for living on planet earth is
streaming right now on Apple TV and it
is I'm sorry
Apple TV Plus and you've got to check it
out please welcome the very funny Chris
O'Dowd how are you Chris
ah here corner lovely to see you I love
the way you say my name I again you know
they say that thing about I know if we
talked about this before but you know
the way the Irish accent has that
reputation for being romantic or
something yeah if I worked it out
scientifically that it's the elongation
of the vowels because a consonant gives
a word its power yes a vowel gives the
word it's feeling so the longer those
vowels are either engaged if that's what
makes it sound all sexy like elongated I
love that it's just elongated you know I
grew up next door to these twin brothers
that were in probably in their 60s the
Murphy boys and I was a kid and I'd be
out shoveling snow and the Murphy boys
would be out there talking to each other
and they were from some small village in
Ireland I couldn't understand a word
they were saying you know people think
it's the Lucky Charms elf what should be
Gorda it's not the real thing when you
hear it it's impossible hey hey hey it
doesn't I do I never understood a word I
think they were both calling for help
and I never understood like laughs see
exactly how are you doing you're in your
house yeah quarantined how first of all
how's your wife is your wife handling
this well yes she lives in the otic no
run a week and a half ago I believe her
last words were I never want to see any
of you again good she's been she seems
happy I hear a lot of men's voices up
there but
seems to be she sends the odd text yeah
and that's great you know that feels a
little pick-me-up in the middle of the
day you know it's good I'm glad that
she's meeting other people and that
she's in the attic and she know it's
been brilliant actually the whole thing
I just could
who knew that what we needed was just
more time together you know like a an
endless infinity amount of time like
that we are operating at only 24 hours a
day so sad to me I just wish it was more
time for more questions and more time to
notice little things that each of you do
that might be annoying yeah we need more
of that you know I know you're from
you're from Roscommon that's right and
where is Russ common but it's kind of in
the northwest just east of Galway me old
very useful how is you must have family
there how are they doing with the virus
how are they with the quarantine is it
are they handling it well I think so I
mean my my mom and dad are still in my
hometown and Boyle and their cocooning
which is this thing that you were is law
so they can't leave the house if you're
over 70 Oh which is pretty full on yeah
um but my mother it seems to be dealing
really well with it she's a therapist so
she's been doing a lot of zoom perfectly
and things like that and then she's kind
of just waiting at home the rest of the
time waving out the window paper I like
to think of her like this adorable
golden retriever seemed pretty good and
then my sister has five kids so she very
ages so she and her husband are just
it's like a I might manic holiday yeah
he's doing okay you know it's I think in
Ireland there is this there's been tough
times
before so in a way it's kind of like the
notch on the bedpost of our collectors
historical seniors it's funny cuz I
always think the Irish expect things to
be bad you know yeah and so when there's
a global pandemic and it's the world
seems like it's going to [ __ ]
the Irish are like well of course yeah
right we hope we did have a feeling this
was gonna
there's also I we're here in California
which is a very different experience I
think in Ireland where we're like okay
so you can't go outside you can't really
see each other and you know it's kind of
dangerous I think a lot of Irish people
were like you need like winter over here
it's being a little kind of different
yeah yeah exactly yeah very true very
ready for it you have two sons ages two
and five is that right that's right
that's right I have to say not knowing
anything my kids are older my kids are
in their late 60s makes it a very
different experience to have a
two-year-old and a five-year-old I think
would be very difficult right now to all
be in the house together this is the
situation so we've got five-year-olds
who's getting out of like nighttime
diapers the two-year-old is getting out
of daytime diapers a dog who's having
accidents because he doesn't get walked
as much and a cat who is 16 and seems to
really hate us it is an avalanche of
excrement and urine in my pre pampers
commercial that's been quite intense the
potty training which we just started
when all of this for want of a better
word [ __ ] shows began was was
unfortunate like it just it just all
kicked off and now it's it's everywhere
else so that's your life your life
your life is dealing with just a house
filled with excrement 24/7 it's a gauge
of Phillips yes everywhere with the
bedroom I think this is why your wife is
in the Attic but they've been great it's
been great and I just need to work out
what my first favorite dinosaur is
because that seems to be important I've
been far too much credence to the
importance of the first floor but here
yes yeah well we all know it's the
brontosaurus yeah you mentioned speaking
of creatures you said you have a dog yes
what's your dog's name
potato why did you do that the time we
were in London Oh you look kind of like
a potato like I remember there was some
angel that we've actually forgotten and
now whenever I'm in the park people
think I have Irish Tourette's listen he
has a trick I'd love me to see oh I want
to see this okay
it all seems too on-the-nose but this is
I mean this is something I discovered
that he could do one day when I was just
watching TV watching the show mm-hmm
which will be familiar with and the teen
tune came on and this happened
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
potato only only does that when he hears
the office theme song the office theme
song I've no idea why there must be some
note in the music not me buddy because
when it first started potato was looking
down ah ears twitching thinking and then
it got to the certain part of the song
and oh yeah there's maybe than you
there must be an instrument change in
there somewhere but it's amazing oh
that's such a sweet trick that's so
amazing that you found the one show
either potato loves or potato can't
stand you when your team song comes on
he doesn't a farm that's quite sweet
like it's just as regular yeah yeah I'm
sure that means it really loves the show
that's my guess I want to make sure we
talk about this because you've made this
new animated short film and you it's
it's really lovely it's and it's a great
message here we are
notes for living on planet Earth let's
talk about it because how long has it
been in the works for I probably got
involved in around a year ago there's an
Irish kids altar called Oliver Jeffers
and we have a bunch of his books he
breaks he's a youngish guy he's probably
my age and from Belfast and I bumped
into him at a u2 gig and we kinda stayed
in touch and hear John the animations
for the backdrop in Madison Square
Garden it was really cool and we had his
all his books and happened to be reading
him to the kids and then they got in
touch and said they were doing this so
it seemed to make sense it's a gorgeous
story about explaining the world to a
child
basically it's young kids thing and it's
it's really adorable and it's a kid who
basically is wants to know everything
about Earth
wants to learn is everything he can
about earth and it's an animated film
that's only what half an hour long it's
30 minutes right right it's it's like
for TV so it's like yes it's a half hour
yeah Meryl Streep kind of pleased that
she's been now raised her who's kind of
mother earth and myself and ruth negga
paired parents and Jacob Tremblay but
it's it's very sweet
they're kind of it's set around Earth
Day and the kid wants to go to the
museum and his parents are essentially
saying let's go out and see the world
the timing isn't idea but but it's a
beautiful little tale of just trying to
break things down into the their
simplest form so they can be consumed by
it well so it's a nice message this is
our planet this all we have we got to
take care of it which so far so far yeah
yeah I'm sure we'll find another one
very soon
yeah but that'll be three years away
it's this is all so you've done your
fair share have you've done some work in
animation you've done voices are your
children aware do you have have you done
stuff for your children can watch it and
say oh wait that's that's dad yeah yeah
we raised it kids show on Netflix called
puffs and rock these guys from Ireland
and it's very gentle and easy show just
set on like clips somewhere it's very
sweet so for the first kind of when you
when we started watching letting the
kids watch TV was all we would let them
watch because it's so gentle but it did
mean for good two years they thought I
now rage at all of television which is
maybe an idea it's sweet
yeah nice that they thought their father
was really the center of the universe
this was my experience when my kids were
young they would fall in love with the
show and then they would get me they
would love it so much that I would
mention the show in interviews then the
people who ran that show would reach out
to me and say Conan do you want to do a
voice on the show and I'd say sure and I
would do it in it's animation so it
wouldn't come
out for a year total year later I'm
gonna get the kids to outgrown that show
hey you know I'm on the goo-goo brothers
maybe like we hate the brothers no one
watches the googly brothers
well we're into now is Teen Titans go
and I said like okay great and then I do
that and be like no no we outgrew that
oh shoot
so I was always behind always behind
yeah what so how do we how do we remedy
that I'm you're gonna need to get on
trend for kids stuff of the future yes I
know I know
I think what I have to do now is forget
them and aim for grandchildren
that's what I have to do I have to have
to start working on something now that
will come out in 20 years
tomorrow see ya and you thought it was
an idiot I read that editorial you wrote
[Laughter]
weird thing for me to choose no the iris
usually piss on the iris right well let
me try
I mentioned this here we are notes for
living on planet earth is now streaming
on Apple TV plus great and everyone
should check that out because it's like
yeah and this was nice of you to take
time away from the excrement the bitter
feelings between yourself and your okay
yes yes yes yes
okay we'll uh okay yeah I know it's
great it's just a little eating at home
you know it's great being at home and
I'm so happy for you that you're gonna
be there there's gonna be a van that
comes to your house and get in the back
okay don't ask any questions okay John
thank you very much for doing this
you're a good sport
you're a fine lad if that's something
people really say
Chris Oh dad god bless you be well be
well